we see the opportunity in this country
still to be very significant the
chameleon is disheartening as it is
particularly for the employees in our
view whilst its early stages doesn't in
any way deflect from our attraction to
this country to continue to invest in
the infrastructure of this country
Aussie pension funds have really blazed
a trail in terms of infrastructure
investment how come their UK
counterparts have been a bit slower off
the mark I think there's a couple of
factors that have gone into that firstly
your pension fund market here is a lot
more fragmented there's thousands of
schemes in Australia there's hundreds of
schemes and whether for my Australia or
the fourth largest pension fund market
in the world
so with that concentration it's enabled
larger funds to use that scale benefit
they have to invest in large-scale
infrastructure projects now that I'm
really encouraged to see that with the
local government pension initiative here
to consolidate into eight super boroughs
if you like I think that's a very
positive step that should enable those
funds to get more exposure to what we
call the illiquidity premium that comes
from infrastructure and some degree of
certainty that also comes from the
income stream that follows from
investing in these sorts of assets so
yeah Australia has led the way but it's
encouraging to see that some of the
initiatives in the United Kingdom should
likely see that that follow all right
now I'm on the UK assets in which you're
invested the m6 toll roads Manchester
Airport Anglian Water how worried I that
Jeremy Corbyn might come and nationalize
some of those assets look political risk
is real around the world and in
statements like that are frankly
unhelpful you know there is a role
clearly for governments but there's also
a role for private sector and and so I
think that there's a there's a
complementarity to the sorts of capital
about government and private investors
like pension pension public partnerships
like we can bring and they should be
encouraged and supported and and and the
environment should be from a political
perspective welcoming of that and
conscious of the long term views that we
would like to seek emanating from
politicians around the world and in
encouraging us to to be an end state
infrastructure investments very very
briefly money is still cheaper
the world has that pushed up assets
prices too high are you still finding
value we are still finding value it's
harder when there's a lot of private
sector capital looking for a smaller
number of opportunities clearly that
supply demand dynamic does impact prices
having said that we've been and we
remain very active because we're seeing
value in in many parts of the world the
United Kingdom m6 and salt